ich schreib doch gerade der meinung
können wir essen gehen die autofreunde
die sich in kleine monster verwandeln
denn sie nichts zu essen bekommt oder
gehört die vielleicht selbst zu
denjenigen die sich nicht mehr
wiedererkennen wenn sie hungrig sind
angesagt man den englischen eine
kombination aus handy und angry ein
grund dafür ist die ausschüttung des
hormons ghrelin qualysoft dafür das
essen lecker aussieht regt den
speichelfluss an und erhöht unsere
aufmerksamkeit bezüglich essen
allerdings beeinträchtigt kredit auch
diesen teil des gehirns der für
selbstkontrolle zuständig ist was uns
ungeduldiger und impulsiver macht
deswegen räumen wir auch immer den
hallen supermarkts in den einkaufswagen
wenn sie hungrig einkaufen gehen
außerdem läuft unser gehirn auf kurse
also auf zucker kein anderes organ ist
so stark von glukose abhängig wenn wir
länger nichts essen sinkt unser
blutzuckerspiegel und unser gehirn
empfindet das als eine lebensbedrohliche
situation ihre stärke deswegen kann man
sich mit hunger auch kaum mehr auf was
anderes konzentrieren
hinzu kommt dass ein fifa blutzucker die
ausschüttung der stresshormone adrenalin
und cortisol triggert diese
stresshormone haben unseren vorfahren
wahrscheinlich noch geholfen um auf zack
und damit schneller laufen zu kommen wo
er studiert
harmlos party wird es nur noch dazu dass
wir unseren mitmenschen grundlos an
schnauze
besonders betroffen davon sind die
menschen die uns am nächsten sind unsere
freunde familie partner bei ihnen unsere
selbstkontrolle ohnehin schon am
niedrigsten ist die kamera - für meinen
am besten hat man immer irgendwelche
snacks in der tasche aber vorsicht diese
typischen junk food snacks wie
schokoriegel geben euch zwar ziehen wie
schnell ein mega zuckerschock der aber
genauso schnell wieder abfällt und ihr
findet euch möglicherweise kurze zeit
später in einem noch tieferen perry loch
wieder besser wäre da ein gutes
deutsches vollkornbrot andersen kann dir
sagen diskutiert keine wichtigen sachen
mit leerem magen sondern verschiebt bis
auf nach dem essen dann gibt es noch
weniger streit
hey ich bin ihm und das ist schön schlau
übrigens adrenalin und cortisol das sind
zwei stresshormone die auch bei kaffee
ausgeschüttet werden deswegen kaffee auf
leeren magen klingt hier außerdem euren
café zur richtigen uhrzeit wenn ihr das
wissen wollt dann schaut mal hier drüben
ansonsten teil dieses video mit euren
freunden wenn es euch gefallen hat geht
es den daumen nach oben und vergesslich
zu abonnieren
dann sehen uns wie mich nicht donnerstag
wieder bei schön schlau